uh what advice would you give to people
who are struggling with depression
and maybe for the people who love
the people who are struggling with
depression
so what i have found to be most
successful for me um
it's it's back to the basics of
everything that the
therapist or psychologist will tell you
psychiatrists will tell you right when
you meet them which is
exercise every day
eat
healthy
for sure
find time make time every day to do
something that you love
whatever that may be whatever brings you
joy
and you might and when you're really
depressed that actually feels like
nothing because the things that brought
you joy
don't bring you joy anymore when i'm
really in the thick of it
but um
for me all like this is the cycle that i
i'll go through is i'll look at my life
and i'll say okay what what what can i
clean up all right well
for me it was
cutting out alcohol actually helped me a
lot
um
i know that sounds like big i'm not like
not judging anybody for that and i still
you know drink on occasion but i felt
like alcohol has been very unhelpful to
my mental state
um
i feel less drive and less happiness the
next day for things that i want to do i
feel like it plays a lot with your
serotonin so look for stuff to change
clean living yeah clean living but also
understanding that that sometimes it's
just
it just is
and you just keep breathing
and and it will get better with time
this too shall pass this past like i i
really think that uh in the winter you
know i i'm pretty sure i mean i've had a
lot of i've seen a lot of therapists and
all of them say the same thing which is
like you have major depressive disorder
and this is what it is but
it's certainly worse for me in the
winter months so i know there's like
um i can't think of the term for it but
there's a term for like seasonal
depression there it is um
so i'll get to the winter and suddenly
i'm like geez everything really
sucks on a deeper level
and then you know so it's like this too
shall pass is another thing it's like
just
practice those things absolutely see a
therapist that's my big like my biggest
emphasis of life is to like on stage
like my goal like i have a few things
that i really really care about one is
is is mental health health and
destigmatizing therapy because for me i
didn't go to therapy for a long time
because i felt that it would be
admitting that i was broken it'd be
admitting that i was weaker than
lex who doesn't have to go to a
therapist because lex is stronger so be
strong like lex
you know i would like to look at all my
older brothers and i looked up to them
so much and they're all these incredibly
successful people plastic surgeon an
anesthesiologist a dentist two attorneys
stanford nyu like just like incredible
high standards
eagle scouts you know like
they valedictorians like they just did
it all
so for me
i was very
really did not want to admit and none of
them went to therapy
so it was like what are you going to be
are you are you broken are you like the
weak one who can't hack life
and i think that's incredibly dangerous
um and i feel like it almost cost me my
life because i took so long
to finally go to therapy so i really
want kids to know
hey like the great people that achieve
great things that are doing amazing
things they probably have help almost
all of them it's like going to the gym
but it's a mental gym what um so i
unfortunately i wanted to be a
psychiatrist when i was growing up
uh
maybe maybe that's why i like podcasts
maybe that's i think you'd be a good one
maybe
i would i would i think you are a
psychiatrist pretty much right
sounds like you're a psychiatrist i
think i need more i i think
i i think actually to be a good
psychiatrist you also need to be seeking
therapy from the like you also need to
be have some stuff to work through in
your mind right
i think uh yeah you have to have gone to
some dark places
um
empathize
the the empathy it's this ability to
empathize and especially if you've
directly
experienced it you can
you can go to those places in your mind
like you said it's with the music to be
authentic you have to really go there
what um
why
did therapy help so much what is the
process of therapy if you can just
educate a little more is it
are you basically bringing to the
surface and talking through things
that you
because of the
the momentum of life you just never
allow yourself
to speak through to think through is
that what therapy is or is this a more
systematic thing
so i've been to a lot of strange
different kinds of therapies so i'll
tell you my first therapist if i could
sort of corrupt uh how hard is it to
find
a therapist that connected with you
it is
it's actually pretty hard i think i
think i think uh it for
well actually i have a skewed view of
that because
going back to the beginning of my
therapy was with a mormon
therapist so it was very much like
well are you reading your book of mormon
and are you praying at night you know
what i mean like that was a big focus of
my therapy to begin with and you're
having yeah a faith crisis in the
distance
like well
and then you're making it worse yes the
next therapist i went to
was
uh
a scientology therapist i met my wife
and she was scientologist at the time
and she's not anymore
which is like
it's such a funny thing to like to look
back on because we met and i was like
this mormon missionary who just got home
from his mission and i met her and i was
she's a scientologist i was like wow
that's bad [ __ ] crazy like
and like that stuff's crazy and she's
like what are you talking about that's
your crazy
mormon that's bad [ __ ] crazy and the two
of us were like
huh
maybe there's something to this to both
of us here yeah the tension actually
forces you to think through like oh well
what is true yes yeah and we really fell
in love through that which was like
maybe that we're both on the wrong track
let's figure this out but before that
happened we went to uh
a
scientologist therapist
who that therapy consisted of what have
you done wrong
to asia and they asked they would ask me
that question over and over and over and
over until i'm like thinking of the
deepest darkest things that were in the
recesses of my mind this was a therap
this was marriage therapy
anyway i'm not gonna get into that but
it was it was scientology therapy so
that was a different thing and then i
went to
therapy therapy like no not attached to
any religion and that was a really great
experience for me and and since then
i've been through a couple different
therapists but that was more because
where i was and moving and things like
that
so is it that hard to find a great
therapist probably not but maybe don't
go to your mormon therapist personal
psychology therapist
or maybe that's maybe that's the route
for you maybe it's around for you i
don't know yeah but what is so is it
bringing stuff to the surface basically
oh yeah so i didn't even answer your
question what's the effect why is it so
effective just um i is there something
you could put words to
yeah i mean i think it's obviously
there's the common things you would
think of which is like i've been holding
these things in and i don't want to tell
anybody and then i tell this person and
there's relief in that but that's really
not where the real work comes from i
think the real work is meeting with
someone who is well-versed and educated
and understands
it's like it's like coding it really is
it's like someone who like they listen
to you and they're like well that was a
trigger and then this became this
trigger and you're probably every time
you're hearing that thinking of this
thing that happened earlier in your life
and they just will walk you through
scenarios and maybe some of them aren't
right but some of them you'll be like
it'll resonate sometimes you're like wow
i am feeling that because of that and
that did happen and maybe if i call my
mom and say this to her it will make me
feel better hey mom this happened it's
like work you you put in work and you
have hard conversations and do difficult
things and if so if your therapy is not
difficult
i actually think that's that's not good
therapy good therapy is it's going to be
a little difficult it's work
like um during and after yes like i had
this incredible therapist who was who
i told him when i was going to do
ayahuasca he was like jesus you know he
he actually was a doctor before and a
really well educated studied person who
had
walked away from uh brain doctor what's
the word for that brain doctor a brain
surgeon neurologist oh yeah neurologist
and he uh
and he's and he said well basically his
belief was that the uh ayahuasca was
like
basically doing therapy like 50 sessions
he was like it's it's like really
intense if he's like
you i don't know if you want to do that
if you do you can you can make you know
some big steps forward but i prefer just
to do one once in one session at a time
and um
so yeah it's hard work and and
that i typically like it's really hard
for me to talk about ayahuasca by the
way going back to that because i'm not
looking to tell everybody to go to
ayahuasca it's incredibly hard it was
the scariest experience of my entire
life it felt like i went to heaven but
it also felt like i went to the darkest
deepest hell that was
incredibly scary
um
incredibly scary yeah
you